recently got away with this he's running  a private unregulated cut set of  companies right he had his private  holding company paper bird he had  Alameda a private company he had FTX a  private company no transparency no  disclosure if you were running a public  company you got to actually publish  audited financials every quarter and  make 8K statements and you have adult  supervision you I have lawyers Banker I  have two sets of lawyers two sets of  accountants you know an army of an army  of internal accountants external  accountants  Etc and if I just came on your show and  said hey I just wanted to announce that  microstrategy has 175 000 Bitcoin my  phone would start ringing by the lawyers  put that down they'd be like what are  you doing you're crazy yeah and you know  they would say it not just because it's  wrong they would say it because their  careers are on the line and they don't  want to spend 10 years in litigation  health